Alexander wenberg leans in for the Kraken
he'll be opposed by stro and wenberg wins
it alexc slides it across the top oh that shot
changed Direction mccan got another crack at
it and doall makes another save left off last
game against the Flames this is a tough little
redirect and he just gets that left toe but
look how quickly he regain or excuse me bakan
and again dord with a good save as he Shrugged
that one off here's a turnover behind the that
Leon comes up with it Clips it in it goes off of
dord and he grabs it off with the catching glove
and theor took the bottom of the net away and
that time dor got a little lucky Kraken recover
possession and an Airborne centering pass in
the slot is finally tipped Away by McTavish
mome joins the rush brings it in on right wing
great pass across and McTavish denied by dord
that's a nice Rush from his left to his right cuz
this this is a pass it zipped I mean Jackson the
puts a lot on that pass and Mason didn't waste a
lot of time but you could see the timing of the
goal tendered the cord was just perfect squeeze
that right arm up against the body so there was
no space whatsoever for mavage again to the line
duns pass off escap pouched on by Lon goes right
up the gut short-handed break toor with a stop
real nice play by Carrick forced to turnover
Brett Leon was a way to the races tried to jam
it back comes mccan across the line with wber
he remain scoreless and the Kraken stay on
the power play Vince Dunn now handles almost
coughed it up but it went right to mccan slides
it over and they score yor strand makes it one
nothing well that was quite a shot by Bor strand I
mean he just tattoos that top Corner took it away
and you want to see a good shot that's a great
shot shot look where that puck goes just off the
inside of the post and then up into the top of the
net into the playoffs for Seattle well you talked
about that Coachella Valley Thunderbird team
went all the way to the AHL caller Cup Final as
dord with another acrobatic save handed through
is it Terry that I think it is chops this back
yeah and dord got there again arson has always
been a physical shot blocking presence formerly
of the to Oilers and now Tatar finds paneers oh
he makes the pass done with the Finish it's two
nothing this is a really well executed outnumbered
attack dun's the weak side defenseman and he's
going to jump up into the attack but little
hesitation right here by veneers looks everybody
off and and that is a touch beautiful touch
pass mean he's kind of rolls it off the heel
of his stick angles that blade back just a
little bit to elevate the puck those are some
hands done head man's up the left side tar got
it to Everly's behind the defense stick handles
around but sticking the left P out toall keeps
it out Jordan Everly moments ago good little
flip pass into Everly he never really got that
puck to settle down to the last second and he's
looking at the puck that's the opportunity for
the goal Pender to get real aggressive you see
that guy they have both Mavish and zis on this
top unit and Jamie D getting a rep on the blue
line along with color and Terry and this one gets
the glass off the Stick of Drive field came over
the top of the net and landed back in the blue
you know the right strategy from the power play
that initial shot by Drive show goes right over
bounces off the top of the crossbar you shot Troy
Terry coming off the draw Henrik controls Fowler
moves it into that bump position stro off the wing
through traffic Carrick had a hack at the rebound
still digging for it and dord has it oh Henrik had
a chance and the Seattle net Miner keeps it out
on their rebound opportunities haven't been able
to get that puck Airborne you can see theor just
patiently stays down there and there's the bid by
Henrik but he gets it about a foot and a half off
gourd to oppose Henrik on the draw to the right
of the Seattle net and it's in the feet of Henrik
and Hammer Ho by The trono no fooling around with
Frank it's two to one he know that that was going
to be a shot and Frank vrono who's been snake bit
recently gets all of that one and he just hamers
it and the shot is perfect it's just going to go
over top of the right pad of the golender so
it's it's just at the right height it's over
the pad under the blocker and he got all of
it I mean there not much that the court can
do about that big Power Play goal for the Ducks
Deon Shore looking for someone coming late he
finds Duman to the high slot Duman uses that
Long Reach back in front for c one more pass
to Shore and his bid block by lome and a good
save on K as it came off the end boards right
to him to stick in to prevent Leon from getting
a real clean CRA and waiting for it on the far
boards was Troy Terry and it's moved up by Fowler
color through center with Terry finds bakan and
joining the rush back rebound got it behind
him but couldn't get it in the that AR by do
sty but here's the one that hurts right here big
rebound top of the crease the go sender badly out
of position and Alice K just pulled it a little
bit Thomas tar gave a little sh ridden off the
puck and Tolen and throws it across Jones had
to go through him and then couldn't get to the
boards to get it Fowler throws go it ahead they
catch the Kraken on a change here's McTavish toor
with a save if it doesn't hit the Blocker of
the golender that that might have had a chance
but still 2-1 Seattle as the cracking get it
into the Anaheim Zone Carrick ridden off the
puck but Johnston follows up and Ross will send
it in off the corner boards Leon ripped it oh and
that one off the heel of the glove came up at
two a piece here's the dump in and here's the
shot that goes off the actually the thumb of
the golender dord wow that was fortunate and
now Seattle the other way dun drops it off
Tatar cuts to the high slot goes backand
scores so often the case a near Miss at one
end in the net at the other 3-1 Seattle but
nobody there to cash in look at the Patience
by thear keeps going keeps going and from a
pretty severe angle he's able to hoist that
up and again elevating the puck that is so
key Thomas tar making it look like a pretty
good pickup and Anaheim still has it Fowler
almost lost it lost an edge and now does
lose it bork strand trying to feed it to
mccan behind the defense but a good recovery by
Fowler minakov brings it back in drops it off to
zis Trevor takes it in by behind the net he scores
a lacrosse goal exactly what Alli Lowe's off ask
for
wow he's moving I I've seen a lot of guys try
it but not while they're skating at almost full
speed what a Play What a Beautiful play by tror
Eis it's just amazing amazing hand I think most
of the the crowd is just now realizing what
he did cuz they showed the replay a couple of
times on the big board above Center ice and the
reaction got a great deal louder it's his second
of the season so the Ducks now just down 3-2
as Lon trying to come through the neutral zone
knocked off his stick trailing the play as mnov
pabble to the corner in front Le R by the glove
hand of Joey dor what a stop Brett Leon has
had so many chances he does everything right
here gets a puck up in the air but it's right
into the glove of the court and you know what
we've talked about this when things unfortunately
this one kind of run out of time in this game you
know you just had the feeling that the Ducks
had the momentum Unfortunately they couldn't
get a third Puck behind Joey dord you think of
the near misses that the Ducks had in this game